recognising patterns and applying them
in new situations may be two key
features of language and thought but
what happens when the patterns wrong
last time I pulled out a critter you've
never seen before
ash ruff and I think we agreed that we'd
immediately know what to say if I had
five or six of them but that's not
thanks to the SH ruff so much as it is
to our understanding of plurals there's
a paradigm for plurals in English and it
works for words big and small short and
long so we have reason to be pretty
confident that this is just how plurals
work in English then eventually we run
into somewhere that doesn't fit the
paradigm we've abstracted and analogized
this general idea about plurals but it's
inadequacy is staring us in the face
this roadblock is not just a problem for
the grammar of English plurals if you
ever had to fight your way through some
basic logic before you noticed that we
use general statements like all this or
every that to draw conclusions but just
like with mice and alumnae we're always
at risk of running smack into something
that doesn't fit with the general
statement we've worked so hard to
abstract and apply by analogy if you
were living in the 1700s and your name
were David Hume you would have pushed
this point very hard wondering why from
this experience we form any conclusion
beyond those past instances of which we
have had experience this gets called the
problem of induction and it asks us
frankly why we should have predicted
that the plural of mouse would be
Mouse's just because the plurals of
other words end in ns of course if I'm
learning English this seems like a
fairly trivial event I note the
exception I hope that I remember next
time and I move on
but not all failed applications of
paradigms are this mundane Nassim
Nicholas Taleb uses the metaphor of the
Black Swan swans are white not black or
so Europeans thought until british
ornithologist John Latham stumbled
across real-life black swans in
Australia the Black Swan has since
become a mascot for rare events that
have a surprisingly huge impact these
abnormalities strike us as obvious after
the fact just as obvious as it is to an
English speaker that mice is the plural
of mouse and to modern avian enthusiasts
that not all swans are white we can of
course incorporate this new information
and maybe even be a little smarter with
our paradigm by hedging against big
unknowns but can we go the other way
let's turn to plurals just one more time
children might get corrected for saying
Mouse's sure and they might step in line
but at some point english-speaking
children applied this same paradigm
incorrectly but instead of incorporating
the correction they grew up to overturn
old norms sometimes we simplify other
times we preserve the irregularity and
there's even room for creativity as
brand new patterns emerge
as we learn about language and thought
and use thought and language to learn
exceptions to the rule can give us some
useful feedback about the patterns we
think we see
you